- Today I'm here to go against
everything I've ever said on my channel,
and to ask you guys to please
stop meeting strangers, for now.
Let's just, let's take a little break.
I know things suck right now,
and everything feels really weird,
like it's hard to put
into words how I feel.
Like the other day I just
started crying for no reason,
like literally nothing had happened,
I was just sitting there
and I started crying.
I keep zoning out multiple times a day,
and when I snap back into it
I can't even remember
what I was thinking about.
Like are you guys going
through this as well
or is it just me?
At least every night I have a nightmare
and when I wake up, it feels
like I'm waiting to wake up
from another nightmare, but I never do.
This must be a little weird
because my channel is about other people.
And I never share anything about myself.
But I'm doing that today to show
that we're all in this together,
and to emphasize the importance
of what I'm about to ask you guys to do.
The kindest thing you can do for yourself,
the people you love, and
strangers you'll never meet
is to follow the protocols.
Social distancing, please stay
away from social settings.
Wash your hands, don't touch your face.
I know this is hard because
we're all social beings.
Trust me, I would know,
I meet about 400 new people every week.
But it's really important that we do this.
When you're at a store,
and you wanna grab the
last two hand sanitizers,
just remember that the
stranger next to you
is just as scared and in
need of the hand sanitizer.
So take one, leave one for them.
Something common, I just touched my face.
Something common I've been
hearing from young people
is that they shouldn't be worried
because coronavirus isn't gonna kill them,
but what about your mom
and your grandparents,
and people who have a
compromised immune system.
If you're not worried about yourself,
please keep in mind people
who are the most vulnerable.
I already know some people are gonna say
that people like me are overreacting,
and that there's no need
for videos like this,
and I hope you're right, honestly.
I hope that in a month all
the comments on this video
are making fun of how much
I overreacted about the coronavirus.
Because that would mean
that there was some sort
of solution by then.
I genuinely hope that's the case.
But if that's not the case,
then I couldn't live with myself knowing
that I could have done more.
I honestly do think that
our actions right now
could literally save lives.
And we can all be heroes.
I know we always imagine heroic acts
as like jumping in front of a car
to push someone out of the way,
but just think now you don't
have to risk your own life
to save someone else's life.
In fact, you might even be
saving your life as well,
so it's just way cooler.
With that said, I will
continue to post every Thursday
here on my channel, meeting new strangers,
I'm just kidding, I'm not
meeting strangers anymore,
face to face at least.
Instead I'll be asking you guys
to send in videos, or
to send me your numbers
so I could FaceTime you.
And I'll announce the topic
for that week's episode
either on here, on my YouTube channel
in the community section,
or on my Instagram and my Twitter,
mainly my Instagram,
I still don't really
know how to use Twitter.
I think it's important with
everything that's happening
for the first topic we
discuss to be the coronavirus.
So if you've personally been affected
by the coronavirus,
and you're willing to share your story,
please email me at
thorayaproject@gmail.com.
Yeah, that's all guys,
thank you for everything.
Be kind, stay safe, I love you all,
and I'll see you next Thursday.